bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados la atención
internacional alrededor de taiwán se ha
incrementado en las últimas semanas
desde la visita de la congresista
estadounidense nancy pelosi china inició
ejercicios militares sin precedentes
alrededor de la isla y también eeuu ha
hecho ejercicios con fuego real en la
vecina indonesia a qué se deben estas
tensiones qué estatus político tiene
taiwán y cuál es su relación con china y
eeuu taiwán es una isla situada a 120
kilómetros de la china continental
aunque actualmente cuenta con una
constitución propia líderes elegidos
democráticamente y unas fuerzas armadas
con cerca de 300.000 soldados su estatus
político es altamente complejo los
líderes taiwaneses sostienen que se
trata de un país soberano y gran parte
de la población prefiere conservar el
llamado status quo con el que goza de
autonomía sin apoyar en ni la
independencia ni la anexión a china pero
beijing considera que es una provincia
separatista y está determinado a
anexionarla así por la fuerza rechaza
también que cualquier país y en especial
eeuu reconozca a este territorio como
independiente conozcamos un poco de su
historia tras haber estado bajo dominio
japonés cuando terminó la segunda guerra
mundial japón que había ocupado este
territorio entregó taiwán a china sin
embargo china entró en una guerra civil
y en 1949 mao zhedong tomó el dominio
del país ese año su rival el líder
nacionalista hacían caisse que huyó a
taiwán desde allí aseguró representar a
toda china y prometió que retomaría el
dominio de todo el territorio pero esto
es algo que nunca sucedió con el nombre
de república de china taiwán fue
reconocida como nación soberana por
varios países occidentales e incluso
ocupó un asiento en naciones unidas sin
embargo en 1971 la onu dio su
reconocimiento al gobierno de beijing y
expulsó al de taipei actualmente
solamente 13 países más el vaticano
reconocen a taiwán
como ha sido la relación de taiwán con
eeuu eeuu como una gran mayoría de
países ha mantenido lo que se conoce
como ambigüedad estratégica por un lado
respeta la política de una sola china
es decir que reconoce a beijing como
gobierno legítimo de china pero al mismo
tiempo mantiene relaciones comerciales
con taiwán desde 1979 además el congreso
estadounidense prometió suministrar
armas a taiwán y así lo ha hecho durante
décadas incluso cuando en 1996 china
realizó pruebas de misiles orientadas a
taiwán washington contestó con un amplio
despliegue militar en asia luego durante
la presidencia trampa la casa blanca
permitió a diplomáticos estadounidenses
establecer el lazos con homólogos
taiwaneses lo que no gustó a chivas y
más recientemente el presidente
estadounidense joe biden afirmó que
defendería a taiwán en caso de una
invasión lo que ha crispado aún más los
nervios de beijing que intereses
comerciales rondan a taiwán taiwán juega
un papel de gran importancia a nivel
internacional pues domina el 60 por
ciento del mercado y la de los
semiconductores a escala global una
industria trascendental para el
crecimiento económico y militar de
potencias como eeuu y china estos
elementos electrónicos son los que hacen
posible la producción por ejemplo de
teléfonos inteligentes tabletas
computadores automóviles y también el
desarrollo de la industria militar en
los últimos años taiwán ha crecido
económicamente de manera exponencial
incluso en 2020 durante la pandemia
taiwán tuvo un producto interno bruto
positivo del 35 % y buena parte de este
crecimiento se debe a la industria de
semiconductores en ese aspecto taipei
comparte con beijing y washington
grandes lazos comerciales eeuu es su
segundo socio comercial sólo por detrás
de china país con el que taiwán se ha
vuelto altamente codependiente
económicamente el gigante asiático
importa nada más y nada menos que el 60
por ciento de los semiconductores a
nivel mundial según el servicio de
investigación del congreso
estadounidense y gran parte de éstos
provienen de taiwán pero eeuu también
tiene una fuerte dependencia de los
semiconductores de taiwán empresas como
apple importan íntegramente estos
elementos tecnológicos de la isla en
medio de las tensiones washington teme
que china pueda invadir este territorio
y obtener el control de las fábricas más
avanzadas de microchips que existen
actualmente pero para algunos expertos
es justamente el aporte en materia de
tecnología de taiwán al mundo y
particularmente a china lo que impide
una eventual invasión a su territorio no
obstante un posible desarrollo de esta
industria en otras partes del mundo
podría cambiar el tablero del juego si
le sirvió el vídeo para entender la
situación de taiwán y su relación con
las dos principales potencias mundiales
los esperamos en otro episodio de en
cinco minutos en france 24 y france24
puntocom